et aujourd'hui la communauté
internationale craint une surenchère de
violence dans la région jusqu où vent
les ca on va t-on vers une nouvelle
guerre à gaza c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec un
jacques benillouche journaliste
indépendant à ses côtés gilles devers
avocat au barreau de lyon spécialiste en
droit international bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être en direct sur rt france
aujourd'hui évidemment chacun se renvoie
la balle comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs
quand ces conflits éclatent
quelle est la réalité du terrain selon
vous jacques benillouche aujourd'hui ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que il y
a déjà dix minutes ça fait 3 inverse que
nous recevons novo cathy la leyre sa
dernière vient de sonner il ya une
minute je suis en train de vous parler
alors qu'elles sont encore c'est à dire
que nous avons le risque de recevoir des
missiles aujourd'hui j'ai entendu donc
tout à l'heure plusieurs détonations
on nous a assuré que c'était le dôme de
fer qui intervenaient et donc
effectivement on n'a pas été touché pour
l'instant mais le risque existe donc
vous êtes en plein je dirais qu'en plein
direct vous vivez la situation que nous
vivons
trois alertes en même pas cinq minutes
quand je faisais les tests avec votre
technicien j'ai eu la première hammer
ceci c'est pour dire la situation que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
alors vous comprendrez que ça peut
passer ces détails peuvent être beaucoup
plus important que tout ce dont on va
parler et pour lesquels nous allons
essayer de deux d'être clair et
d'apporter une réponse si possible
neutre je vous laisse la parole monsieur
et je reprendrai après parce que je suis
dans une période de tension suite à la
lettre qu'ils à lui est à l'heure
actuelle sa bombe
on entend les bombardements allaient
alors gilles devers à enliser est avocat
et donc spécialiste en droit
international parce qu'il est beaucoup
question de droit évidemment dans ce
dossier et c'est toujours compliqué
selon le point de vue où l'on se place
ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres en
l'occurrence cette fois ci c'est
notamment le sort des familles
palestiniennes menace
d'éviction à jérusalem il y a ce report
de l'audience clés prévus dimanche au
dernier sur ce sort de ces familles
gilles devers on rappelle qu'en début
d'année le tribunal de district de
jérusalem avait rendu une décision
favorable à ces familles juives qui
revendiqua on le rappelle des droits de
propriété dans le quartier de cheikh
jarrah rld secteur palestinien occupé et
annexé par israël
selon le point de vue toujours qu'en
est-il au niveau du droit
j'ai très bien je vais vous répondre
avec le plus de précision à 10 ans qui
vit dans ma nature locuteurs moi je n'ai
pas les bombes donc je suis plus rare
mais ça n'empêche pas d'avoir là le
devoir de traiter les questions voilà
bon je veux dire également que je suis
pas neutre sur ce sujet vu que jacky
revient pour nombre de palestiniens de
gaza de jérusalem-est de cisjordanie
pour les réfugiés je suis un avocat des
palestiniens notamment devant la cour
pénale internationale
et ça fait maintenant douze ans qu'il me
demande d'appliquer le droit en tant que
technique à leur situation d'apporter
cette précision puisque voilà vous êtes
effectivement dans un face à face avec
deux points de vue
différents et c'est bien le but de ce
débat dont je vous laisse poursuivre
voilà donc moi je suis pas de chez pas
d'adversaire qu'on soit bien d'accord et
je suis très content de rencontrer
monsieur mais c'est vrai que je défends
un certain point de vue
bon on parle de droits alors pour aller
à l'essentiel
vous évoquez cette décision du district
très bien très bien elles existent moi
je vais en parler d'une autre que j'ai
amené ici un et qu'on va voir
c'est là une décision de la cour pénale
internationale
elle date du 5 février 2021
et qu'est ce qu'ils disent est cette
décision elle dit que la palestine est
un état et elle dit que le peuple
souverain et le peuple palestinien et
souverain sur gaza sur la cisjordanie et
sur jérusalem est dans les frontières de
donc là je donne pas mon point de vue je
donne un état de droit il s'était à de
droit il n'est pas jugé par une
juridiction locale
il est jugé par une juridiction
internationale les israéliens ont
participé à ce débat y avait le barreau
d'israël événements de personnalités ont
participé à ce débat juridique moi j'ai
participé au nom de victimes
palestiniens en étant quand c'est donc
affronter juridiquement mais c'est votre
thèse qui a perdu par la voix de
monsieur mais c'est la thèse israélienne
qui a perdu vu que l'état de palestine
est reconnue avec une souveraineté sur
des territoires dont quand vous parlez
de la situation elle ne cherchera et de
ce tribunal moi je vous dis le débat a
changé de nature et il va falloir que
les juges s'en rende compte aussi parce
que ils n'ont plus compétence la cour a
tranché 1967 s'opposent en droit
international et un juge israélien gère
les affaires à l'intérieur d'israël mais
il n'a pas compétence pour juger des
affaires sur jérusalem occupée qui fait
partie de l'état de palestine selon le
droit international
donc il ya tout un travail qui est à
faire il faut remonter à toutes les
situations
mais que ce soit pour la situation de
ces personnes ou que ce soit pour les
ponts par demande qui ont lieu sur gaza
mais également les tirs qui viennent de
la résistance armée
eh bien il se trouve que la palestine
tout tout eu toutes tendances politiques
confondues avaient donné
d'accord et accepte le travail de la cpi
est d'accord pour travailler sur le
droit international
alors qu'après l'arrêt du 5 février
israël a dit qu'il ne participerait pas
donc nous sommes du côté du droit
international et en défendant les unes
palestinien je défends le droit et je
suis très à l'aise dans une émission
jacques benillouche quelle est la
position d'israël sur ce point on parle
pas forcément de la vôtre mais mais mais
d'israël sur ce point puisque monsieur
devers nous y voilà c'est le droit
international la cour aux pédales aurora
international a jugé est-ce que cela
fait foi aux yeux de l'état hébreu
également je vais vous dire que le
tribunal de ces pays n'a aucune valeur
pour israël
il n'est pas reconnu par les américains
israël reconnaît pas ce que ce ce
tribunal qui n'a aucune aucun sens
donc à partir du moment où les
américains ne reconnaissent pas ce
tribunal
pourquoi venez-vous qui serait le
reconnaissent et beaucoup d'autres pays
ne reconnaissent pas la validité de la
validité de ce tribunal
donc pour l'instant israël ne veut pas
tenir compte de ce qui est dit et je
préfère les décisions internationales de
l'onu des comptes du conseil de sécurité
ou des pays
ceci dit ceci étant dit si nous allons
commencer à parler de juridique bien
nous n'allons nous allons nous enfoncer
dans des débats qui seront foireux il
faut parler de choses concrètes
vous avez dit vous avez dit que vous
êtes engagés
moi je suis un jardin un journaliste non
engagées c'est à dire que je n'ai pas
que 2 de carte de parti et je
n'appartiens à aucun parti mais j'essaie
d'être réaliste j'essaye d'être réaliste
si nous sans arrêt nous sortons nous
revenons à des aléas les préceptes
juridiques qui sont contestés par les
uns et par les autres
nous n'avançons pas aujourd'hui il faut
avancer
il y à une situation grave là je viens
encore damas d'avoir une deuxième à
l'est une deuxième but de 4e à l'air
donc c'est quand même une situation
moi ce que je trouve en dehors de tout
contexte de tout contexte juridique
moi je trouve que envoyer des missiles
sur des peaux
une nation civils est un crime et là je
le vis moi même je le vis moi même ce
que c'est que de recevoir des missiles
alors que nous sommes
je pense nous je parle comme nous
c'étaient les habitants de ce quartier
qui vont recevoir des bombes
nous sommes innocents donc comment
peut-on accepter que quelqu'un la même
chose dans l'autre sens vous le savez
jacques benillouche et c'est tout le
voilà le côté explosif james confie
iliad est ni à plaire plus de morts du
côté palestinien ça c'est un fait donc
c'est vrai mais qui a que robin commencé
à dire qui a commencé alors je suis
d'accord avec vous qui a eu des
provocations de la part de la droite
israélienne
jeudi elle à l'extrême droite
israélienne qui a voulu en pleine
période de ramadan s'installer en plein
centre de la ville pour essayer de
montrer sa présence est contestée
effectivement la situation de certains
arcs mais le problème c'est que il
s'agissait à ce moment-là de
contestation je le dirai humaine et non
pas militaire
il sait est la réponse à cette
contestation a été l'envoyé de l'envoi
de missiles je maintiens que cette ce
problème là est parti d'un problème qui
n'était pas militaire
et nous serons nous nous retrouvons avec
des missiles qui nous tombe sur la tête
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on va régler le
problème alors que gilles devers
pardonnez moi ce qu'il fait distribuer
la parole gilles devers quand on entend
jacques benillouche nous dire voilà ce
sont des gens d'extrême droite c'est
vrai que c'est ce qu'on entend souvent
chez des israéliens qui n'ont pas envie
de cette escalade de violence et qui là
déplore ce sont des extrémistes
justement des deux côtés qui font un
petit peu le le voilà qui met le feu aux
poudres dans ce conflit clairement c'est
votre opinion aussi on a clairement vu
qu'il y avait des manifestations
provocatrice est une chose mais le fond
du débat va au delà c'est à dire c'est
la question de jérusalem est et tout le
projet c est ce que jérusalem est
capital unique de l'état d'israël où est
ce que jérusalem fait partie du
territoire palestinien alors qu'il faut
pas d'arguties juridiques mais je veux
bien qu'ils aient pas dans l'ue si je
dis alors de quoi on parle
moi je dis si vous voulez la paix c'est
comme cela il va falloir accepter la
cisjordanie palestinienne la gaza par
les signes haine et jérusalem investi
liens etc la cpi qu'il dit israël
reconnaît pas la cpi mais cessons droite
se mettre en dehors du droit
international mais déjà faudra pas
fallait faire des leçons de droit
international quand on leur jette c'est
une première chose
et la deuxième chose c'est que sur
jérusalem est
vous avez des résolutions du conseil de
sécurité le conseil de sécurité dire on
ne reconnaît pas le changement de
constitution qui est nul et non effet et
on ne reconnaît pas l'unification du
jérusalem jérusalem et reste du
territoire palestinien donc tout ça
c'est ce sont des questions indique
indissoluble donc il ya une part pour
l'oeuvre provocation qui est certaine
mais les juges qui s'occupe du
territoire peu palestiniens n'ont aucune
compétence et je vous dis que nous
allons être amenés parce que nous
n'avons pas d'autre solution vu
l'acharnement de ses juges a déposé
plainte contre eux vigueur il se met
complice de la colonisation dont grèce
mettait les frontières la charte de
l'onu en son article 7 10 la garantie de
la paix dans le monde c'est le respect
des frontières dans guérilla une
frontière dans jérusalem
il va falloir sortir les israéliens de
jérusalem-est et rendre à jérusalem est
complètement palestiniens c'est 1,6 ya
des juifs qui elle venir c'est autre
chose
de la même manière si des musulmans vous
installer en israël où des chrétiens
sais c'est pas un problème de religion
c'est un problème de statut voilà et il
se trouve que à ce qu'on voit très très
bien et que deux d'un côté certainement
des groupes organisés mais regardez du
côté palestinien je suis proche de tous
les groupes politiques que tous tous
voila j'ai des contacts avec tout ça
c'est mon métier d'être en contact avec
tous d'être un petit peu un avocat
diplomate mai
à jérusalem c'est ni le hamas ni encore
moins le fatah abbas n'a aucune autorité
sur jérusalem et le fatah non plus c'est
une jeunesse qu'est ce qu'elle vit cette
jeunesse et le dire on vit ici on veut
vivre là que c'est tout et ça c'est pas
une question d'extrémisme et je me suis
le dire c'est pas une question d' alerte
à la bombe
donc rester en israël comme compétence
comme capitale palestinienne
c'est jacques benillouche pardonnez moi
avant de vous laisser répondre voudrait
un kirby peut cesser réactions
internationales qu'on sent parfois gênés
d'ailleurs par le silence assourdissant
de joe biden pour le moment l'union
européenne par la voix de joseph bourrel
nous nous dit voilà il faut condamner
les déclarations d'un côté par une
provocation d'un côté mais aussi de
l'autre ça veut dire que la communauté
internationale a par moscou qui nous dit
quand même qu'il y à du droit qu'il faut
le respecter ne semble pas être dans un
camp ni dans l'autre semble un petit peu
embarrassé dans cette affaire pour ne
froisser personne
je pense que si on se place
essentiellement et le croquant la
spécialité de mon interlocuteur si on se
place uniquement sur le droit on va
avancer parce que les problèmes que nous
avons à leur pied sur des problèmes
politiques
vous savez que les manifestations durent
hamas ont été lancées par le ramasse
parce qu'il voulait impliquer israël
dans la décision de mahmoud abbas de
reporter les élections
les mahmoud abbas à reporter les
élections
donc il fallait pousser le qu'israël à
intervenir pour permettre que ces
élections aient lieu
sssa l'origine de l'un d'eux du problème
on n'a pas parlé de jérusalem lors de
ces manifestations
les gens qui sont intervenus non pas
parler ils ont demandé des droits de
pouvoir faire les élections comme elles
ont été prévues seulement mahmoud abbas
sait qui va les perdre parce qu'il est
enfin 2 en fin de course
il sait qui va les pertes il a une très
forte il a une très forte opposition au
sein même du fatah et c'est à ce moment
là que l'on veut impliquer israël dans
un conflit entre fatah
ramage je voudrais vous signaler que et
ça n ai plus jamais intervenu à gaza il
a quitté gaza en 2005 droit et il
n'intervient plus jamais à gaza il
intervient il n'intervient pas à gaza il
n'y a pas de troupes qui occupent gaza
il n'y a pas il ya des frontières quels
qu'ils sont respectés d'un côté comme de
l'autre
vous avez le la frontière avec keren
shalom au tous les jours 600 camions
traversent la frontière pour apporter de
l'alimentation et des devait et des
matériaux à gaza mais mis à part cela il
n'y a pas de contestation qui s'exprime
donc si vous voulez uniquement vous
basez sur le côté juridique on en a des
années à discuter et c'est parce que
monsieur est avocat au barreau de lyon
et spécialiste en droit international et
et de la cause palestinienne
je comprends qu'ils s'appuient sur des
choses qui ne sont pas par exemple vous
avez parlé de jérusalem jérusalem a été
reconnue par les etats-unis et par
quatre autres pays occidentaux
jérusalem est est donc alors et alors ok
alors c'est à dire quand même une mais
ces calaisiens gigue de droit il ya le
son de cloche il ya le son de cloche de
certains pays octroyant son de cloche
les modèles phares usine de verre le mot
de la fin s'il vous plaît la réponse à
jacques benillouche c'est ce qu'on
arrive déjà au terme de ce débat il ya
le droit et les arguties juridiques donc
réussi juridique je pense que je suis
pas là dedans mais les palestiniens et
non d'un état est un état ça passe par
le droit pour là c'est comme cela et là
c'est pas des états unis qui font le
droit des états unis viole le droit
depuis hiroshima donc c'est irien 9
voilà maintenant elle veut dire que
c'est le hamas qui manipulent jérusalem
alors j'allais presque dire
il aimerait bien mais l'implantation du
hamas à jérusalem est extrêmement faible
il ya simplement des gens qui glissent
promis touche bosso et donc bon endroit
selon evo et vu qu'on a un égo on doit
participer à la vie
une égalité de droits entre un
palestinien israélien ça aussi c'est du
droit l'égalité de toutes personnes donc
le peuple continue à demander à livre en
prêt dans ses frontières
ils se trouvent etc une zone occupée
juridiquement s'est dit par tout le
monde y compris par le conseil de
sécurité
je suis étonné que vous avanciez des
arguties aussi glossy forces
internationales insolite internationale
qui virait le gaz et les postures et
après la casse et des conventions de
genève
alors quand plusieurs blocs lost ya pas
un seul soldat israélien à gaza et gaza
le blocus parler les bateaux les la
surveillance permanente les raids
permanent le nombre de morts qu hélas il
ya les opérations c'est un blocus et
c'est d'ailleurs vous traitez israël la
question ou casar soir le ministère des
affaires étrangères et par l'armée avec
une délégation militaire et si vous
laissez passer des camions c'est parce
que vous avez l'obligation en fonction
de la convention de genève
vu que c'est un territoire occupé gaza
est un territoire occupé
merci vous êtes retiré des colonies vous
vous êtes retiré vos soit en conscience
tranquille mais elle donc ça c'est exact
mais tendresse informé que juridiquement
il sera gaza est occupé et non seulement
occupé sous blocus militaire ou violet
vos découvertes et l'egypte et on peut
pas dire qu'il y à un blocus alors parlé
avec l'egypte et demandez vous mettra
pas d'accord ce soir ça fait des
dizaines d'années que ça dure en tout
cas merci d'avoir accepté ce face-à-face
messieurs gilles devers et jacques
benillouche merci à vous deux